okay before we go 2022 is almost over so
we thought it'd be the perfect time to
look back at all of the Flawless skits
we made this year
by that I mean all the times we screwed
up
a lot of other cities would have said
hey stop [ __ ] in the streets okay
wait hold on a hammer Yeah well yeah I'm
not sleeping enough
yeah I said what was that last one
I've also been hitting myself in the
head repeatedly with this wooden Hammer
I found
this could be something I don't know I'm
sorry
uh excuse me Janet where is your mask
and why aren't you 30 feet away from me
right now
um because we're both
sorry
I murdered two people
sounds great
[Laughter]
having trouble looking at your face
man have I heard that before how many
things in there like four or five
are you serious well no more than seven
[Laughter]
are you serious well no more than seven
seven
Andy thinks you're cute
and he voted for Trump and he'd do it
again
this guy just stole my watch oh Slow
Down slow down hold on what the hell
were you doing wearing
well we may be doctors but he's on TV
grow up well you do bring a
great
get out of here
[Music]
it's my line
and Ralph who filed a harassment
complaint against me for not ref
I quit because they allow accounts for
extremists and porn and extreme porn
really and this is free yeah
you know what I gotta go I'll be right
back
so let's go this way
oh my God were you just checking your
thumb
your phone on Twitter to see if anyone
knows you left
it break it up
all right I'm sorry guys
I'm really sorry
[Laughter]
thank you to Julie Banderas Adam
jansburg Johnny Joey Jones
[Applause]
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else